while president Trump insists he is
trying to level the international
trading field China calls his latest
move blackmail correspondent rich Edson
has more tonight from the State
Department the Trump administration
promises a second round of tariffs
against Chinese imports and is
threatening a third global markets
dropped with losses across Asia Europe
in the United States the president
contends he's correcting a structural
problem in US trade policy you see
what's happening with China we have no
choice this should have been done many
years ago the president has directed the
United States Trade Representative to
identify 200 billion dollars in Chinese
imports and apply a tariff of 10% if
China retaliates he says his
administration will raise tariffs on an
additional 200 billion dollars in
Chinese goods that's on top of the
tariffs had implemented last week on 50
billion dollars in Chinese imports China
retaliated and says it is not afraid of
a trade war with the US when the
function may fall we advised the us to
remain rational and stop such words and
moves that harm itself and others this
is the only viable way out the Trump
administration has also enacted tariffs
on global steel and aluminum imports
Russia announced today it will soon
release a list of American products to
target with tariffs even American allies
say they'll retaliate still the state
department claims arguments over trade
will not affect other aspects of
international relationships it would
encourage you not to conflate the two
issues because we have complex
relationships with so many countries
around the world where we have things
that we are in total disagreement over
and then we have areas where we are
still working to develop better
agreement over those issues some
analysts disagree especially on China
and its involvement with North Korea
they're not without leverage on this why
the tariffs why imposing tariffs on this
on them will make them more cooperative
I don't see
in less than a week after the Singapore
Summit North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
is in China again his third trip there
to meet with President Xi Jingping the
State Department says the United States
and North Korea have continued
conversations since last week's summit
in Singapore and now to US defense
officials say North Korea is expected to
transfer the remains of 200 US service
members killed during the Korean War
and will do so to un command in South
Korea that of course was announced by
President Trump last week at that summit
ret interesting that third trip I came
to China rich the Trump administration
now announcing the departure from the
United Nations main Human Rights body
why it is calling it a shameless
defender of hypocrisy the Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo joining UN Ambassador
nikki Haley here at the State Department
about an hour ago saying that it had
given the UN Human Rights Council a year
to reform itself it failed to do so
so the u.s. is leaving we take this step
because our commitment does not allow us
to remain critical and self serving
organization instead we made a
good-faith effort to resolve the
problems Secretary Pompeo says the
council has membership on it of some of
the worst human rights defenders
singling out China Cuba and Venezuela
while it obsessively mistreats Israel
and lets other violators go the
Democratic senator Chris Coons said that
it's a mistake for the United States to
leave and that it's better to be part of
the conversation right Richardson live
at the State Department rich thank you